hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for Phil Horne Shaw's review and
progress of gears 5 for a lot of gears 5
you might feel like you're playing
another title straight out of the middle
of this series locust war from back
during the original Gears of War trilogy
much of the game from the gunplay to the
story feels like past Gears of War Games
the Coalition has definitely put a lot
of emphasis on the core cover shooting
elements of Gears that have always been
strong in the franchise but Gears 5 adds
a lot of new ideas to the series and all
of them are useful evolutions for the
franchise that strengthen its core
aspects on the campaign side the
Coalition has worked in some structural
changes that open up how you'll fight
and he encounters you'll get into you'll
still spend a lot of the game hunkering
down in cover and popping up to score
headshots but for the first time you'll
have more options in battle and more
chances to move around and use your
different combat abilities how you fight
your mini encounters with enemies and
Gears 5 is altered most by Jack the
franchise is r2d2 like robot who follows
you around opening doors and hacking
computers Jack now has a skill tree of
abilities you unlock as you play and can
use during combat they allow you to do
things like turn invisible to sneak up
on enemies or stun enemies to force them
out of cover you'll spend a lot of time
amping up Jack's abilities or the
resources you find in the game which is
one of several ways Gears 5 provides you
the opportunity to adjust the game to
the way you want to play it
the middle portion of Gears 5 also
contains two big open-world type areas a
first for Gears of War these areas are
littered with small locations to explore
and side quests to complete all of which
are like mini versions of the larger
Gears levels and encounters you're used
to seeing you can wander these areas at
your leisure and they usually come with
a waiting in Bush possibly a bit of
progression on a side story maybe a
lower drop and an item to improve Jack's
abilities the locations are fun short
diversions in their own right and the
more you explore the more powerful Jack
becomes which is a pretty good incentive
to cruise around and see what's waiting
for you out in the wilderness you'll
also see new kinds of encounters in
Gears 5 you won't always just run into
swarm soldiers spoiling for a fight for
instance sometimes you might catch them
unaware giving you a chance to set up
ambushes or even take out a few or all
of them with stealth the more open
structure of the game means there are
more chances to think about how you want
to approach fights
and more opportunities to change the way
you deal with your hulking foes the open
portions also provides some of Gears
fives best writing as they give the
characters lots of time to just hang out
and talk most of Gears 5 focuses on Kate
one of the new characters introduced in
Gears of War 4 as she searches for
answers about her heritage gears 4 ended
with the implication that Kate has a
connection to the locust and a big chunk
of the game has her exploring the
questions that implication raises but
the best parts of it are the many
conversations between Kate and her Delta
Squad mates which do a lot to flesh out
their characters you get closer to the
characters in Gears 5 thanks to these
conversations it's like going on a road
trip with Delta squad and the game is
great at showing the deep friendships
between its characters through dialogue
unfortunately the rest of the story
campaign doesn't hold up as well as its
smaller character moments do the second
of the games for axe is all about
finding answers for Kate but a lot of
those plot lines get wrapped up or
pushed aside by the middle of the game
much of the rest just concerns the fight
against the swarm threat without
advancing the overall story or the
character beats beyond trying to restore
the Gears series super weapon a hammer
of dawn add to the fact that a lot of
Gears 5 story feels like it's rehashing
old territory and everything feels
basically like it did back during the
original Gears of War trilogy the story
ends somewhat abruptly in Gears 5 and it
feels like the most interesting
conflicts and character moments gets
swept aside to make room for more fights
with big monsters but the additions
Gears 5 makes to the core formula all
feel like thoughtful advancements for
gears of wars identity that goes for the
multiplayer side as well on the
competitive side the coalition doesn't
alter much about how Gears plays you're
still dropping into cover looking out
for players with shotguns and trying to
control power weapons on every map
instead Gears 5 bolsters the experience
with depth the game uses ideas common to
live service titles and they all help
flesh out multiplayer to make playing
with friends feel more involved than
just a series of matches
there are progression systems that let
you advance your character to unlock new
weapons and cosmetic items and
multiplayer provides a lot of different
modes to work through so whether you
want some interesting twists with game
types like dodgeball or more traditional
ring to play with team deathmatch
there's probably something for you
however the live service influence is
most apparent in the cooperative modes
the wave based horde mode is back with
some tweaks that push you to specialize
your team instead of just having a squad
role as an
Gears of War for you now have particular
characters who all have special perks
and ultimate abilities like you'd expect
to see in a hero shooter the same is
true in the new escape mode as well
which has you rushing out of a swarm
hive while you flee from deadly gas but
only whatever limited items you can
scrounge to help you fight your way to
freedom in both cases you'll pick a
character with a particular play style
and those additions help to vary gears
5s gameplay and encourage teamwork
characters aren't that different and
you're still spending a lot of time
hitting chest high walls but the
specialization options also give you the
opportunity to play the game a little
differently and you have through the
last 5 entries in the series you can
even play as Jack in a peer support room
co-op modes also have a ton of
progression systems you'll rank up your
characters unlock new skill cards to
give them better perks and abilities and
even work through seasonal content and
fortnight like battle past pathways it
should be noted there are some cosmetic
items you can purchase through micro
transactions but the Coalition has said
all seasonal content for heard mode will
be free here's 5 doesn't stray from what
has made the gear series strong
throughout the franchise and especially
in its campaign it might be a little too
mired in the past but with so many new
additions this is a meaningful step
forward for the series everything the
coalition adds to the Gears formula
helps to make gears deeper and more open
to a variety of play styles and
approaches whether it's the campaign or
co-op competitive or quick play there's
an option for you in Gears 5 and the new
ideas it brings to the series are all
good reasons for fans to return
you